screen junkies viewers chose Superman as
the winner of our Batman V Superman
trailer battle so here's the honest
trailer for Superman Returns yay before
the boss to the wall may have a Man of
Steel but after the boss to the wall
nonsense of Superman for there was the
balls-to-the-wall boredom of Superman
returns after Warner Brothers cancelled
Superman projects by Tim Burton McGee
and director Brett Ratner prepare for
Bryan Singer's bland mix of omage sequel
remake and reboot in this Hibou quote
that takes everything you love about the
older films and just kind of does that
again originally
so I hope this experience you're buying
as you are flying statistically speaking
still the safest way to travel
Christopher Reeve is Superman and
Brandon Rath is doing a pretty good
impression of him he's the same dorky
all-american hero but with a brand new
twist now he's also a deadbeat dad who
knocked up Lois Lane then left for five
years to go double check on some rocks
but Supes isn't the only throwback at
this Donner Party Kevin Spacey stars as
gene Hackman's Lex Luthor with his life
sentence overturned in the worst court
decision since OJ the appeals court
called Superman as a witness and he
wasn't Lex is free to pursue his stupid
real estate schemes you're building an
island why
with the stupid sidekicks and collection
of stupid wigs whoa no way - that way
grow up to become Jesse Eisenberg after
five years of letting earth fend for
itself
Superman has returned to get back in the
pants of his ex-girlfriend watch kal-el
super stalk Lois Lane
attorneys who still can't spell how many
after they're in catastrophic urn has
the password you would expect Lois Lane
to have try Superman and constantly lies
to her perfect boyfriend about her one
night stand with Superman I spent the
night with Superman come on it was the
title of an interview which means James
Marsden has now lost girls to Superman
Wolverine and Ryan freakin Gosling and
in the end gets rewarded for his loyalty
by raising a kid who might not even be
his you are not Suda in your Sunday best
because if you thought Zack Snyder was
way too on-the-nose with the Jesus
imagery Ryan singer really nail you in
the wrists with it as Superman falls
from the sky doing cross arms has his
side pierced with a spear dies and comes
back to life and floats around in heaven
listening to prayers which is all pretty
ironic considering Superman was invented
by two Jewish guys from Cleveland so get
ready for some of the best Superman
action and arguably the best Superman
action sequence in a film or Superman
rescues a ton of people and yet still
has time to be a boring Moby Dick see
Zack you can have it both ways but don't
let the action fool you watch as the
sleepy remake gets bogged down with tons
of boring stuff like moping newspaper
reading crystal font leg the one song
you can play on piano for Parker Posey
silently reacting to things waiting for
stuff to happen wow that's really
something Lex wait for it and a final
battle where Superman faces off against
an inanimate island aah
starring Christopher Ralph damsel in
distress House of char
Super Muppet psy cloths
kal-el ped the Batman V Superman script
and why is parker posey in this movie
and why is she holding an enormous glass
of olives man of fields so Lois still
doesn't know Clark Kent is Superman even
after they had sex I mean come on so
obvious a child could see it be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers
do not go gentle into that good night
rage rage against the dying of the light
Marvin Tamara the secret of man's red
flower by the hoary hosts of Hogarth
I guess I'm eating pecan swirls yummy
yummy yummy it's going to be pee-pee
pants itty here real soon I've got a ton
of work today
a skeleton do you smell it the smell the
kind of smelly smell that smells smelly